[Music]
on this Saturday night California's
climate change catastrophe epic storms
evacuation even deaths the flooding
experts say foreshadows the future
the LAPD Under Fire oh please don't do
this sir please the Taser death of a
teacher caught on body cam
the regulations indicate that we're
entitled 2 400 per person the long road
to compensate air Travelers why the odds
are not in your favor
place of birth a Toronto Taxi I looked
around like this and the baby was in a
house hi this driver's quick thinking
helped with a very important delivery
global national with para Nasser
evening and thank you for joining us
after a week of week of dangerous wet
weather California is bracing for even
more rain at any other time it would be
welcome news for the drought ravaged
state but this is the eighth storm in
under a month and the saturated ground
can't handle it
in the past few weeks California has
seen up to 600 percent more rainfall
than usual more than 25 million people
are under some kind of weather watch
tonight to put that in perspective for
you that's more than 60 percent of
Canada's population as Jennifer Johnson
reports in our top story tonight with
the death toll already higher than
California's past two Wildfire Seasons
combined people are being warned to stay
on high alert
Californians are taking it one storm at
a time as Relentless rain floods much of
the state destroying homes businesses
and closing roads and highways
millions are growing weary of this
dangerous weather do you have that level
of just a little bit of anxiety about it
you want to prepare and as far as what
we have done you know sandbags getting
ready for it many residents have just
finished cleaning up from the last storm
and burst it to the wall within five ten
minutes that we had about six or eight
inches of water and then it started
filling up even more and now it's
raining again more Rivers and Creeks
across California are expected to flood
this weekend officials are especially
concerned about the Salinas River which
is breached its levees just over an hour
south of San Jose the rising water is
threatening to cut off the Monterey
Peninsula home to Big Sur and Pebble
Beach from the rest of the region it's
concerning people are being flooded you
know roads are being inundated so you
know it's nothing to to make small of
evacuation orders have been issued for
more than 17 thousand local residents
you really want to respect mother nature
and you don't want to play around with
that major highways are literally
crumbling shutting off people from basic
necessities like food and water
officials are trying to keep as many
roadways open as possible but the
saturated ground is causing multiple
landslides if we end up closing roads
the impact on our community would be
significant and devastating downed trees
continue to cause power outages giant
sinkholes are opening up First
Responders continue to tell residents to
stay home after several people have been
swept away in high waters those not
evacuating wonder how much longer they
can protect their homes it's going to
rain for the next three days so that's
kind of like where we're at right now
anticipation kills you still
Californians are trying to stay
optimistic as another atmospheric River
pelts the state with yet another one
still coming
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
some experts say this parade of storms
reveals a symptom of change we may see a
lot more of in the future weather
Whiplash abrupt swings in weather
conditions from one extreme to the other
California has experienced periods of
drought for decades but now the skies
have opened up with devastating results
the rainfall normally seen in a year has
deluged the state in just days storms
one after another turning neighborhoods
into lakes now what's typical for
California to have winter rains and dry
periods during the summertime but what's
different now is the intensity climate
change is making droughts drier and
longer and the rainfall Relentless the
warmer the atmosphere the more pressure
it holds fewer storms are coming but
when they do it's like a meteorological
fire hose right now California is
experiencing a series of atmospheric
Rivers long narrow bands of water vapor
in the sky these Rivers seen here in
dark green and yellow hammering
California this week but despite the
amount scientists say the record rain
won't solve the devastating drought in
the west because the already waterlogged
Earth can't absorb it all this has been
loosening the soil causing roads to
crumble with the potential for buildings
to cave in with them and any more
rainfall even if it's less severe will
only increase the devastation
back to Canada now the busy holiday
travel season is over but air Travelers
are still wiping away the bad taste left
after weeks if excruciating delays and
cancellations across the country and
it's been especially frustrating for
Canadians still trying to make back the
time and money from their ordeal as
Mackenzie gray reports there are growing
concerns that current regulations in
place that are supposed to help
compensate passengers aren't doing
enough to get Airlines to pay what they
actually owe
departure boards full of red have been
the de facto Christmas lights for many
holiday Travelers this year but that
inconvenience often pales in comparison
to getting compensation from Airlines
for those delays and cancellations
Canadian traveling public has witnessed
what we have in the winter as a very
great lack of customer service by the
airline industry the airline passenger
Bill of Rights requires carriers to pay
Travelers for issues like cancellations
and lost luggage but experts believe the
airlines often use loopholes to avoid
making payments in some cases Airlines
will claim falsely that crew shorthaired
is somehow outside their control when a
passenger disagrees with an airline they
can file a complaint with the Canadian
Transportation agency but the agency
admits it could take a while we've got
33 000 complaints in the backlog uh so
at this point we've said that it could
take 18 months or so for a complaint to
be resolved Adrian Carter is still
waiting for a resolution after she her
husband and three young children were
denied boarding flying home to Victoria
last summer that led her kids to sleep
on the airport floor and getting home 24
hours late despite that Air Canada only
offered her 500 a passenger the
regulations indicate that we're entitled
twenty four hundred dollars per person
so times five right that's twelve
thousand dollars that's a big
compensation Air Canada hasn't provided
that compensation so Carter ditched the
process with the CTA and went to small
claims court they are inversely rewarded
by saying oh here we'll offer you a
hundred dollars we'll offer you five
hundred dollars because they know they
know what they owe me they know the
situation the CTA has the power to find
airlines that drag out the process but
they've yet to use it has the CTA ever
uh levied fines against an airline for
failing to provide compensation under
appr
uh no Advocates believe the lack of
fines provides limited incentives for
Airlines to change their behavior in the
worst case scenario that happened to an
airline is that they are being ordered
after two years three years to pay the
same amount that they should have paid
you to begin with we reached out to
Canadian airlines in WestJet near Canada
told us they comply with government
regulations and resolve complaints in a
timely manner but those regulations
could soon be strengthened as the
transport Minister says new rules to
protect passengers are likely to come
into place during the next parliamentary
session Farah Mackenzie gray in Ottawa
thank you for that Mackenzie a report
for the Global Travel industry has
revealed the most punctual Airlines and
airports in the worlds unfortunately for
US Canada barely cracked the list
among the world's top 20 Mega Airlines
Japan Reigns Supreme holding the top two
spots on the list based on on-time
performance in 2022 America's Delta
Airlines ranked sixth the top spot for
North American carriers Air Canada this
nation's loan entry on the entire report
came in at number 20. with an on-time
percentage of just under 52 percent no
Canadian airports cracked the top 20
most punctual around the world or the
top 10 most punctual in North America
there's another widespread problem
plaguing this country that involves far
more critical delays the unacceptably
long wait times Canadians face every day
to get the treatment they need in
hospitals that's the focus of the West
block this weekend particularly
emergency room care David Aiken is this
week's guest host he joins us from
Ottawa for a preview David what can we
expect
well we are definitely going to start
with the crisis in our emergency rooms
of course it was a terrible week for
Nova scotia's Health Care System two
women died after each of them spent
hours in a hospital emergency room one
died in hospital one left after a long
wait and would die at home we're going
to speak to Nova Scotia Premier Tim
Houston about the progress he's been
making or failing to make depending on
your point of view on the promises that
he made during the 2021 provincial
election that he would fix the
province's Health Care System we are
completely focused on fixing this Health
Care situation and our resolve is
stronger now than it ever was we know
that there's a lot of pressure but we
know we can get there too but of course
Nova Scotia is not alone with problems
with its Health Care System every
Premier is facing similar challenges and
every Premier says the federal
government must do more to help pay for
health care in this country but one of
the reasons Ottawa has been reluctant to
boost Health Care transfers is a fear
that new money will not be spent on
health care that some Premier might want
to spend it on tax cuts or something
else so the feds might wish to impose
conditions on any new health care
funding and earlier this week Ontario's
Doug Ford said he would be prepared for
that kind of accountability in exchange
for cash and so with Nova scotia's
Houston so we just want to part the the
federal government to be there as a
partner we we still call for a meeting
with the the prime minister to talk
about some of these things and and just
look look at each other in the eye but
look we're there we're we're focused on
health care and the federal government
is too so let's get around the same
table make it happen now we're going to
spend the whole show this Sunday talking
about the health care crisis in addition
to Houston you'll also hear from two
doctors on the front line Dr Michael
Hallett is the head of the group
representing Canada's Emergency Room
Physicians and Dr Alika LaFontaine is
the president of the Canadian Medical
Association you want to hear what they
have to say pharah look forward to it
David Aiken in Ottawa thanks David
it said it takes a village to raise a
child and the federal government is
offering support to build them
multi-generational households are the
fastest growing type of living
arrangement in this country and gaviola
reports on the cultural and financial
reasons behind the rising Trend yeah
okay Auntie's doing a good job over
there the Taylor home is a full house
three generations Under One Roof me and
my husband and then my two daughters and
then I have a two granddaughters it's
definitely pretty crazy it's a lot of
people in the house so it is a lot of
fun living arrangements that combine
grandparents parents children and others
are the fastest growing household Trend
across Canada according to the latest
census nearly 1 million households in
2021 had multiple generations of a
family two or more families or a family
living with additional people that's an
increase of 45 percent in the past two
decades multi-gen living is most common
among indigenous families and newcomers
from countries where this living
Arrangement is the norm as housing is
becoming more and more expensive people
are looking for ways to economize and
sometimes that means bringing more
people into the household cultural
preferences and socioeconomic
circumstances come into play so does the
need for care for young children the
elderly and those who need assistance
new this year the federal government is
offering a renovation tax credit to
multi-generational households they can
claim up to 7 500 worth towards the
creation of a secondary unit within an
existing home and this can be used for a
senior or someone living with a
disability and all of this is a nod to
this growing trend for the Taylor
household multi-gen living makes sense
as a way to pool resources and maintain
close family ties and I have a young
baby right now so I'm quite happy that
um there are a lot of people around her
you know she'll grow up getting to know
my parents and she'll also grow up
getting to know her cousin as well as my
sister it's a little different from my
life in the Philippines but
uh I like it because I learned a lot of
new things a planned immigration driven
population surge is likely to increase
multi-generational living and observers
say social supports need to be in place
for newcomers forced into tight quarters
with multiple others to make ends meet
and gaviola Global News Toronto
the Los Angeles Police Department facing
tough questions after the death of a
teacher
coming up the body cam video causing
outrage in the U.S
to the war in Ukraine now where Russia
Unleashed another round of missile
attacks on multiple cities for the first
time in nearly two weeks
the strikes flattened this apartment
complex in nepro killing five people and
wounding dozens of others rescue crews
are searching for any survivors buried
in the rubble Kiev was also rocked by
similar attacks but no reports of any
casualties the latest volley comes right
as Ukraine struck a deal with the United
Kingdom the British prime minister today
promised his country will send
Challenger 2 tanks to a Ukraine's forces
it's unclear how many and when they'll
be delivered
Iran has executed a British Iranian
National after sentencing him for what
they say was spying for Britain
in an audio recording of alireza akbari
released by BBC Persia earlier this week
he says he confessed to crimes he hadn't
committed after thousands of hours of
torture on Friday Britain called for his
release calling the death sentence
politically motivated ties between Iran
and Britain have deteriorated in recent
months as efforts to revive Iran's 2015
nuclear pact have stalled
Brazil Supreme Court has now included
the country's former president in its
investigation to the storming of the
capital there chair bolsonaro has been
named among those potentially
responsible for the January 8th riots
far-right supporters of bolsonaro
rampaged through the Capitol in an
alleged attempt to overthrow the
government it happened after bolsonaro
posted a video questioning the
legitimacy if October's election results
prosecutors say he may have incited the
Riot by making those claims one of his
key allies former Justice Minister
Anderson Torres was arrested in Florida
earlier today
the cousin of a black lives matter
co-founder has died hours after being
tased and restrained by Los Angeles
police and we want to warn you this
video is disturbing
body cam footage released this week
shows officers repeatedly tasering
Keenan Anderson on January 3rd he died
in Hospital hours later the LAPD says
Anderson committed a hit and run and was
trying to flee the scene by breaking
into another person's car the 31 year
old was the cousin of black lives matter
co-founder Patrice coolers he was a
teacher from Washington visiting family
in LA
the White House is acknowledging more
classified documents were found at U.S
President Joe Biden's Delaware home than
previously known on Thursday Biden told
reporters he was cooperating fully with
the investigation saying he takes
classified material seriously today a
White House lawyer said a total of six
pages of classified documents were found
during a search of Biden's private
library after previously saying only a
single page was found there
[Music]
I had safer surgery thanks to the health
of a robot a Canadian first is next
Tesla is slashing prices for some of its
most popular cars in a bid to boost
demand price Cuts range from 10 to 13
percent in the UK but are as high as 20
percent in the U.S and new buyers can
expect to save on model threes and model
y's while Tesla has grown rapidly in
recent years it's facing global economic
challenges and increased competition
from other car makers
it's technology the surgeons say adds a
level of accuracy and precision never
seen before the robot assistant was
first used at Dartmouth General Hospital
last fall and since then has been used
during hip and knee replacement
surgeries to ease recovery time and get
patients back on their feet and home
sooner Megan King reports
this surgeon and this robot are making
Canadian medical history we're pleased
to announce that Dr Jennifer Layton has
completed the first robot assisted hip
replacement using the Mako robot in
Canada here at the Dartmouth General
this is adding a level of accuracy and
precision that we've really never been
capable of before and this is going to
be groundbreaking not only for Nova
scotians but for all of Canada the Mako
robot is being incorporated into knee
and hip replacement surgeries to better
specify each procedure to each patient
our ability to 3D plan both before and
during surgery to accommodate a
patient's bony Anatomy their ligaments
their soft tissues and how their joint
moves in space that's just something
we've never been able to do with a
two-dimensional x-ray I spoke with a
recent patient of knee replacement
surgery using this new robot here at dgh
Helen young she says she went into
surgery around 11 20 a.m on December 6th
and was finished and heading home by 4
30 PM that same day calling the process
smooth Leighton says the robot allows
for an extra degree of accuracy in her
work which she hopes will reduce the
rate of revision surgeries those redo
surgeries have a major burden on the
system they take at least double the
time to do compared to a first-time
surgery they stay in hospital for
several days compared to going home same
day or next morning and a huge burden to
the patient as far as the recovery the
risk and the the complications that can
happen as of November 2022 90 of hip
replacement surgery patients at
Dartmouth General Hospital receive
service within 472 days that's quicker
than the 637 day average that 90 percent
of all Nova Scotia patients were served
Within
as the only province in Canada with two
Orthopedic robots and a robust research
program behind it Leighton says Nova
Scotia will have a huge presence in the
robotic space both nationally and
internationally Megan King Global News
Halifax
[Music]
next the unexpected detour and Delivery
for a Toronto Taxi Driver
[Music]
a Toronto cab driver who had an early
morning Fair ended with an unexpected
detour after he stopped a mother-to-be
became a mom and it all happened in his
backseat Sean O'Shea has more on how it
all unfolded
this isn't the normal pickup
it was it was quite an experience and
quite frankly sir I will do it anytime
Vernon Warner's first Fair of the day
here on Prosperity pathway in
Scarborough a pregnant woman asking to
go downtown to a birthing center but as
he drove west of the highway the taxi
driver decided to deviate the plan after
he heard this she need help she said
driver helped me he got off on Markham
Road pulled into a parking lot at this
McDonald's to call for help I was
advised then to carry on and try to make
it to the nearest hospital but the woman
wasn't going to make it that far the
baby's on the way Verna drove into this
gas station while getting instructions
from a 9-1-1 operator as the woman in
labor spoke on the phone with a midwife
who talked her through hold on to the
neck and pull down to the mom
I looked around like this and the baby
was in a hand everything went right
today because he was the person who was
meant to be there for her baby
deliveries and taxis are rare in this
case Vernon's decision to get off the
highway and find a safe place to stop
for the delivery was key Vernon knew
exactly what to do and he engaged he
paid attention and he was empathetic and
understanding and wanting to take care
of her paramedics arrived about five
minutes later and the mother was
transported to Centenary Hospital seen
her baby's son are fine the lady was
quite grateful she was she was really
happy that
it turned out to be me as her driver
and
I think I was the right person for the
job Sean O'Shea Global News he sure was
that's global national for this Saturday
night I'm foreign osser tonight's your
Canada is Kingston Ontario until we're
together tomorrow take care of
yourselves and each other have a good
night